Hasta ahora hemos dedicado muchos videos a
estudiar la Ley de los gases ideales, que nos
dice que la presión multiplicada por el volumen
es igual al número de moles multiplicado por la
constante de los gases ideales multiplicado por
la temperatura medida en Kelvin [PV = nRT]. Lo que
vamos a hacer en este video es intentar modificar
la Ley de los gases ideales para tenerla en cuenta
cuando estemos trabajando con gases reales, gases
en los que vale la pena considerar el volumen de
sus partículas, es decir, que podemos pensar
que sus partículas no son insignificantes en
comparación con el volumen del contenedor. Además,
nos gustaría tomar en consideración las fuerzas
intermoleculares. Así que pensemos cómo podemos
modificar esta expresión, y para ayudarnos un poco
despejemos P, es decir, dividamos ambos lados por
el volumen. Entonces podemos decir que la presión
es igual al número de moles por la constante
de los gases ideales por la temperatura dada
en Kelvin, todo dividido entre el volumen [P=
n RT/V]. Bien, primero, ¿cómo podemos ajustar
esto si queremos tomar en cuenta el volumen real
en el que las moléculas pueden moverse? Bueno,
si queremos hacer esto, necesitamos reemplazar
este volumen de aquí por el volumen menos el
volumen real de las partículas. Entonces, ¿cuál
va a ser el volumen real de las partículas? Bueno,
será el número de partículas multiplicado por
alguna constante en función del tamaño de cada
una de esas partículas, tal vez en promedio,
así que llamémosle V. Por lo tanto, podemos ver
esta como una ecuación modificada de los gases
ideales. Ahora, de repente estamos teniendo en
cuenta el hecho de que estas partículas tienen un
volumen real, pero por supuesto sabemos que no se
trata sólo del volumen de las partículas,
también necesitamos ajustar las fuerzas
intermoleculares entre las partículas. Y sabemos
que en varios casos esas fuerzas intermoleculares
son fuerzas de atracción, así que disminuirían
la presión. Entonces necesitamos algún término
que nos indique justo esto, un término que nos
indique la reducción de la presión debida a
estas fuerzas intermoleculares, así que vamos
a escribirlo: menos el término para fuerzas
intermoleculares -menos el término para fuerzas
intermoleculares-. Ahora, ya sé qué están pensando
algunos de ustedes: "¿Debemos restar siempre?
¿No podría existir alguna situación en la que en
realidad tengamos fuerzas repulsivas entre las
partículas y eso aumente la presión?" Y claro,
podría haber escenarios como ese, podemos imaginar
que si todas tienen una fuerte carga negativa,
entonces querrán alejarse unas de otras lo más
posible, y eso podría aumentar la presión. Pero en
esta situación podríamos restar un valor negativo,
lo que nos daría una suma, y ya está. Ahora,
¿cómo podemos tomar esto en consideración? Bueno,
sabemos por la Ley de Coulomb que las fuerzas
entre dos partículas cargadas será proporcional a
la carga de la primera partícula por la carga de
la segunda partícula dividido entre la distancia
que la separa al cuadrado [F ∝ q₁ q₂/ r²]. Bien,
obviamente si estamos trabajando con muchas
partículas en un contenedor no seremos capaces
de pensar en las fuerzas entre dos partículas
cualesquiera, pero una forma de pensar en
esto será en términos de qué tan densas son las
partículas en general. Entonces estamos intentando
pensar en un término que tome en cuenta las
fuerzas intermoleculares o qué tanto se reducirá
la presión debido a esas fuerzas intermoleculares.
Tal vez este término sea proporcional no sólo a
la densidad de las partículas, la cual será el
número de partículas dividido entre el volumen,
sino a esto multiplicado por sí mismo, porque
estamos hablando de la interacción entre dos
partículas al mismo tiempo, similar a lo que
vimos en la Ley de Coulomb, ya que al final
éstas son sólo fuerzas de Coulomb. Así que
este término será proporcional a la densidad
multiplicada por sí misma, o podemos decir que
todo esto es una constante de proporcionalidad
que multiplica a (n/v)², donde a dependerá de
las fuerzas de atracción entre las partículas
del gas. Y vamos a escribir este término rojo en
la parte izquierda de la ecuación, y nos quedará,
si lo escribimos así, tenemos que la presión más a
que multiplica a (n/v)² = nRT entre el volumen del
contenedor menos el volumen de las moléculas
que tenemos por alguna constante b, basada,
claro, en qué tan grandes son, en promedio,
las partículas o las moléculas de tu gas.
Esta de aquí es una ecuación que compensa bastante
bien cuando estamos tratando con gases más reales,
aquellos que tienen fuerzas intermoleculares y
cuyas partículas tienen un cierto volumen. Y esta
ecuación hace tan buen trabajo que tiene nombre,
se le conoce como la ecuación de Van der Waals,
la ecuación de Van der Waals. Y existen varias
formas de escribirla: podemos escribirla de esta
manera, o podemos tomar esta parte de azul
y pasarla del otro lado multiplicando para
que se parezca a la ecuación inicial. De tal
forma que podemos escribirla como la presión
más alguna constante por la densidad al cuadrado,
cerramos este paréntesis, esto que multiplica al
volumen menos el número de moléculas por
alguna constante y esto será igual a RT.
Y esto parece algo complicado, pero al final del
día es sólo nuestra ecuación de los
gases ideales modificada para tomar
en cuenta fuerzas intermoleculares
y el volumen real de las partículas.